hello this is preshtalwecker and happy
friday the 13th in this video i'm going
to teach you how you can calculate
fractions of 13 in your head
what is 6 divided by 13
i don't think many of you can solve this
problem in your head so i'm going to
teach you a trick
the first step is to multiply
the dividend six by the number seven
six times seven is equal to forty-two
the next step is to take the result and
further multiply it by 11.
so we take 42 multiplied by 11 and
that's 462.
there's a way you can multiply numbers
by 11. i've explained the trick in a
different video
you can also remember that 11 is equal
to 10 plus 1 so 42 times 11 is 420 plus
42.
the remaining calculations will be easy
to do
we subtract 1 from 462 and we get 461.
these are the first three digits in our
decimal representation
the next step is to take the 9's
complement of each digit
these are the numbers which make the
other digit add up to 9.
so five plus four is equal to nine
three plus six is equal to nine
and eight plus one is equal to nine
and those are the next three digits in
our answer
so we now have all the digits
of the answer in order
so 6 divided by 13 is equal to 0.461538
and these six digits repeat over and
over again
so let's do another example let's try 1
divided by 13.
we multiply the dividend 1 by 7
and this part's easy one times seven is
equal to seven
then we take the result and multiply it
by eleven
this is also an easy part seven times
eleven is 77
the only thing we have to remember here
is we want this as a three digit answer
so we should write it as zero seven
seven
now we proceed with the rest of the
steps in our process
so zero seven seven minus one is zero
seven six
those are the first three digits
to get the next three digits we take the
nine's complement of each number
nine plus zero is equal to nine
two plus seven is equal to nine
and three plus six is equal to nine
so those are the next three digits in
the decimal representation so we can
write the answer
using those digits in order
that 1 divided by 13 is equal to
0.076923
and those six digits keep repeating
you can use the same process to divide
any number by thirteen
so why does this trick work
the reason is that seven times eleven
times thirteen is equal to one thousand
and one
so to divide by thirteen is the same as
multiplying a number by seven and then
eleven and dividing by one thousand and
one
there's a trick to divide by one
thousand and one which is where the
subtract one and the nine's complement
come in i hope you liked this video
please subscribe to my channel you can
support me on patreon catch me on my
blog mind your decisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker and you can get my books
listed on my website